Rice is one of the world's oldest crops.
The first accounts of rice farming date
back to China in 2800 BC. It has since
become the world's second highest
produced food, with over 40 thousand
different varieties in cultivation.
Most of the world's rice is produced
and consumed in Eastern Asia. In 2012,
for example, over 400 thousand tons of
rice were consumed. Rice is a
grass-like plant that is grown in
semi-flooded fields. The water acts
like a protective blanket, which helps
the plants survive temperature changes
and prevents the growth of weeds.
However, if a bad storm comes through
and floods the plains completely, well,
after a few days of being underwater,
the rice will die.
Well these are not the best of times
for some farmers in Kwara state, with
at least 458 hectares of rice farms now
lying underwater. Myanmar is the
world's sixth largest rice exporter,
but after weeks of devastating floods,
the country is facing food shortages
and has suspended shipments abroad. As
the world's climate warms, storms that
bring destructive flooding are becoming
increasingly stronger and more
frequent. Over time, this could bring
massive food shortages to parts of Asia
that heavily depend on this crop. As
people clamor to find a way to keep the
rice alive, science may just have the
answer we're looking for.